- A nation reveals itself not
only by the men it produces,
but also by the men it
honors, the men it remembers.
These men did not fight for
the United States of America,
they fought against it,
they may have been warriors,
but in this cause they were not patriots,
these statues are not
just stone and metal,
they are not just innocent
remembrances of a benign history,
these monuments celebrate a
fictional sanitized confederacy,
ignoring the death,
ignoring the enslavement,
ignoring the terror that
it actually stood for.
This is not about politics,
it's not about blame,
it's not about retaliation,
this is not about a naive quest to solve
all of our problems at once,
this is however about
showing a whole world
that we as a city, that we as people,
are able to acknowledge to
understand, to reconcile
and more importantly choose
a better future for ourselves
making straight what has been crooked
and making right what was wrong.